all right now i know that this is not
the most important story going on right
now but i did want to take a little
break from just the the heavy politics
stuff we've been doing for a bit and let
you know about something new that's
going on as many of you know we have
struggled at the show over time on
different platforms we've had uh 99.8
percent demonetization on youtube during
adpocalypse 1.0 about 60 percent
demonetization monetization on youtube
during adpocalypse 2.0 if you don't
remember these incidents the details are
less important than knowing that at any
point there are problems on different
platforms on tick tock we have had
suspensions for
so-called
covet disinformation which was us
debunking covet disinformation we had a
period of about three weeks where we
lost all of our revenue on facebook
for wrongly being labeled covet
disinformation okay we've had all these
different things
uh we are now experiencing similar
issues on instagram as many of you know
roughly a hundred thousand of you who
follow us on instagram we publish our
content to instagram it's another
platform with a ton of users and we want
to be there
we learned last week
that on instagram our account is being
limited
because of supposedly false content
about covid or vaccines that we have
disseminated and in fact for most users
if you try to mention david pakman show
which is us on instagram you get a
message which says can't mention david
pakman's show because they have
repeatedly posted content that goes
against community guidelines on false
content about covid19 or vaccines what
on earth how could this possibly be
i went and looked well what are the
clips that are supposedly
false information about covid or
vaccines there's only two such clips
that were removed
one
is where we covered
that um
dr fauci
wanted a fox host fired over a kill shot
comment there was a fox host who talked
about fauci and used the phrase kill
shot which suggests violence against dr
fauci we covered that
and the clip was removed
the only other clip
that uh we have had removed
by instagram is one in which we covered
uh we simply posted a um
a sort of political cartoon about the
reaction
to
prior tragedies
um pearl harbor 911 and then the number
of people dying from covid which is well
well well higher
and how for many people there's no
reaction whatsoever that was also
removed and flagged as spreading coveted
disinformation it was actually saying
we're not taking covid nearly seriously
enough can you imagine
i looked up
what is the instagram policy
on condemning covid disinformation or
debunking covet disinformation and very
clearly the policy is we allow content
shared
to condemn
or to debunk we condemned a fox host
using the term kill shot talking about
dr fauci we condemned the lack of care
from so many in the united states about
what at the time was 3 200 people a day
dying of covid and we are now being
limited on instagram because we are
spreading covet or vaccine
disinformation now you would say well
there's got to be an appeals process
david you've got to be able to appeal
this there is but you can only appeal
this ruling if each of these decisions
has a case number attached to it which
ours do not so we quite literally cannot
appeal an insane decision now i know a
lot of people say oh but david this is
the censorship you've been advocating
for no it's not
that that's not true
i have been saying these companies can
have terms of service
and if i agree to the terms of service
and i abide by the terms of service
then there shouldn't be any issue the
terms of service are being misapplied we
obviously aren't spreading covet
disinformation or vaccine disinformation
so
if you work at meta facebook instagram
and you think you can help with this
please get in touch with us info
davidpakman.com i would very much
appreciate it when we had an issue on
facebook about a dozen people in the
audience who work at facebook got in
touch and we were able to get it
resolved it took almost a month but we
were able to get it resolved if you
think this is something you might be
able to help with please get in touch
info davidpakman.com
we just want to keep publishing our
stuff that that's all it's that we
clearly have been caught up in some kind
of dragnet that's that's more
conspiratorial than it is clearly some
kind of algorithm has misidentified our
content that's all
and uh we would appreciate help with
that and of course as always as we've
said before
every revenue source we have other than
our website memberships has been cut at
some point in the past it's happened
with instagram facebook twitch of course
tiktok youtube all of it so the best
insulator for us so that when these
things happen they don't really affect
our revenues
is to get a membership on our website
joinpakman.com and you can do that
you can use the coupon code big voting
22
sort of a coupon code to encourage
voting and participation in the midterms
big voting 22
you can use that to sign up at
joinpakman.com
uh and it really it really does do a lot
and it helps to at least partially
protect us from when things like this
happen so let me know if you work at
meta facebook instagram info
davidpakman.com if you think you might
be able to help